[Music]
dancing with the star season 24 kicks
off Monday March 20th ET caught up with
the seasoned pros to find out who's
going to lead the pack who do you
consider your biggest competition right
now I have to say that the talent that
we have in this cast especially on the
female side I think it's the strongest
that we've ever seen on Dancing with the
Stars I think the girls are gonna
dominate a lot this season and I think
that the male celebs we've got our work
cut out for us
you know we're gonna have to really put
the work in to try and get up there but
I think I think Vaughn is capable of it
I mean he's so talented he's beautiful
but who's Bonners biggest competition um
honestly I think Rashad is gonna be
incredible and I'm actually really
excited to see Emma with him with a
young athletic partner yeah she can do
anything with and I think it's gonna be
fun for them and I think maybe Nick The
Bachelor Nick vile I think he's got some
moves
who are you looking forward to seeing
from some of the other couples see
Charro so are you you are I think I just
like can't wait to watch him yeah I am
afraid not sudden she's funny
yes he's also very aggressive with her
funny you know men so he's like all in
your face and break oh my god I'm
excited about I think mr. t you know
just because the did I didn't I make
sort of image this guy is
I'm personally super excited about Chris
Kattan I think he's you know he has that
personality
I love them from his from his work from
the movies it ladies have your boarding
passes right and then valid no money
yeah right I think I think they're gonna
be amazing and I would dare say that
that's how biggest competition in terms
of like dance ability right you know and
vowels on the high
he's a defending chair he's the
defending champ and then before that was
Peter Peter wonder season before that
dude with that I'm just gonna try to
keep it in the family
[Music]
you